on jouera merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors je vais me
le dire protocole sanitaire allégé dans
les écoles qu'en pensez vous
écoutez les bras les bras nous en
tombent quand même là parce que sue les
la situation à l'école et elle relève du
chaos
cia il ya énormément d'établissements
scolaires en france où il y a
effectivement entre un tiers et la
moitié des élèves qui sont qui sont
absents moi je vous l'avais rappelé je
suis responsable syndical en armes dans
mon établissement je suis enseignant
dans un lycée il ya 92 élèves contaminés
au co vide pour un lycée qui a autour
d'eux je dirais autour de 1100 élèves
c'est c'est considérable et on était
dans une semaine d'examens banalisée
c'est à dire que les flux n'était pas
les flux normaux ils étaient plus moins
importants que d'habitude dont j'ai eu
cours avec une grâce là moi ce cet après
midi
j'avais 60 % des verts absents
quelle continuité pédagogique dans ce
cadre là quel sens ça de parler de
continuité pédagogique
dans ce cadre là et face à une situation
sanitaire extrêmement préoccupante qui
fait quand même que dans la rue un peu
partout en france désormais on remet le
masque à l'école on avance on a vu un
protocole a depuis cette semaine qui
était complètement
incompréhensible et inefficace puisque
on l'a bien vu la circulation du virus à
l'école je viens de vous le dire et est
considérable et là on décide de l'aller
j'ai donc écouté on marche littéralement
sur la tête m'a rencontrée nous le
ministère cette semaine on a demandé
effectivement plus de moyens plus de
moyens matériels des mesures on n'a
toujours pas de purificateurs d'air
devoir
de mesures draconiennes à la hauteur des
enjeux et la réponse du ministère c'est
vous dire vous allez on va alléger le
protocole bon bah écoutez c'est
totalement c'est totalement comme on est
incompréhensible
oui alors l'exécutif allégé ce protocole
sanitaire parce qu'on va le rappeler y
avait beaucoup de parents d'élèves même
d'enseignants qui avait jugé ce
protocole sanitaire très lourds très
compliqué même flou c'est pour ça qu'il
a été allégé on le sait en plus les
centres de vaccination les pharmacies
sont saturés c'est très très compliqué
pour les parents d'élèves d'aller faire
dépister leurs enfants et vous parlez
vous de mesures draconiennes
qu'aurait-il fallu faire alors fermé les
écoles complètement
il ya des mesures il ya d'abord excusé
moi avait on avait surtout dit que le
protocole était incompréhensible
c'était pas qu'ils soient trop lourd
c'était qu'ils soient incompréhensible
et extrêmement confus en l'occurrence
pardo nous on est dans les salles de
porc très inquiet sur la situation parce
que là un virus qui circulent je vous le
dis dans mon établissement il ya 92
élèves positif aucun vide ça
m'interpelle je crois un an et donc
jamais vous allez trouver un enseignant
en france et en aba qui va vous dire il
faut alléger le protocole non il faut
effectivement un certain nombre de
mesures pour enrayer la circulation du
coc vide voilà c'est ça la réalité et
céder des mesures draconiennes et des
mesures effectivement pour diminuer les
flux pourrait effectivement faire en
sorte que dans les salles de cours et
bien on est des mesures un peu plus
étoffé que ouvrir les fenêtres ça fait
des mois qu'on nous dit ouvrez vos
fenêtres enfin quand même mais de quoi
parle-t-on là est-ce que alors je sais
bien monsieur blanc caire va un peu
partout sur les plateaux de télé et nous
dit tout va très bien madame marquise et
quand il communique c'est sûr des médias
privés payants mais dont les salles de
classe dont le monde réel les familles
les élèves les profs sont très
préoccupés et il voit bien qu'il n'ya
pas de continuité pédagogique
comment voulez vous madame que je fasse
cours avec 60% des électeurs de mes
élèves absents voilà et en sachant que
dans la semaine qui va venir forcément
vu que rien ne montre un une
décélération de la circulation du virus
ça va encore plus accéléré voilà on
marche sur la tête écoutez je ne je ne
je ne peux pas dire les choses autrement
et et encore une fois il y aurait des
situations y aurait par exemple la
possibilité de revenir à une demie jauge
à l'échelle d'une classe c'est pas à
l'échelle d'un établissement va il ya
des mesures mais il faut faire quelque
chose on ne peut pas se contenter de
dire bon bah vous savez quoi vous avez
finalement moins vous testez et puis ça
ira mieux sarah désengorger les
laboratoires mais ça va rien poser comme
solution à l'école ça c'est sûr oui on a
vu dans des écoles primaires maternelles
hand et des classes avec plus de 20
élèves qui fonctionnait avec trois
quêtes cinq élèves par jour on le sait
on à une vague qui déferle beaucoup en
tout cas sur les écoles quels sont
aujourd'hui les solutions selon voie qui
pourrait satisfaire à la fois le corps
enseignants et parents d'élèves limiter
les risques face au co ville et assurer
la continuité un pédagogique a assuré un
cursus scolaire de qualité à nos enfants
il ya pas de miracle
dans les lycées c'est comme dans les
hôpitaux si nous sommes en guerre contre
le virus comme le disait emmanuel macron
l'année dernière alors fatalement on
peut pas dire aux gens on est en guerre
et finalement leur donner des moyens
qu'ils soient les mêmes à moyens
constants ou même des moyens moindres ça
n'est pas possible il faut des moyens
supplémentaires nous on avait dit depuis
de longue date qu'il fallait
réquisitionner des bâtiments publics
pour pouvoir justement permettre en plus
une plus grande distanciation des élèves
on avait parlé aussi de moyens humains
supplémentaires il ya plein
d'établissements où on a plus d' aveux d
où on a c'est à dire de les assistants
d'éducation à on en a beaucoup moins
parce qu'elle a beaucoup qui sont
contaminés donc il nous faut des moyens
humains exceptionnels il faut des moyens
matériels exceptionnelles d'aidé des
détecteurs de co2 des purificateurs
d'air voilà ddd des moyens effectivement
quand est-ce qu'on peut tracer
éventuellement testé à l'école quand
est-ce qu'on peut effectivement alors on
vous dit les enseignants vont avoir des
masques ffp2 à la fin du mois enfin en
bref en réalité on est dans
l'improvisation permanente est plutôt
que là aussi faire de la communication
il faudrait décidément mettre des moyens
supplémentaires
je rappelle qu'il ya un certain nombre
de pays de parmi les pays européens où
on a fermé les écoles voilà donc nous et
pas forcément ce que l'on demande mais
si on veut pas en arriver à cette
situation là parce que le virus explose
une fois pour toutes eh bien il faut des
mesures fortes je vous en ai cité un
certain nombre depuis que nous discutons
et qui soit autre chose qu'une usine à
gaz comme le protocole qui a été proposé
à la rentrée en nous disant ne vous
inquiétez pas tout va bien se passer et
là maintenant ou du jambon va c'est un
peu compliqué pour là c'est un peu c'est
un peu trop lourd donc on va alléger les
choses enfin je rappelle qu'on est
jusqu'au à la fin du mois de décembre
ont le protocole qui était proposé ces
deux protocoles de niveau 2 voilà et on
n'est toujours pas passer au niveau
supérieur la réalité c'est celle ci donc
c'est un chaos voilà et est en réalité
bien tout va bien se passer
mammare en tout cas merci d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes enseignant et
porte parole cgt 94 martiel